martine michel davet d'hélène buzzati
bonsoir bonsoir
un tour de table sur cet horrible drame
qu'est ce qu'on peut rajouter avec ce
qu'on a dit depuis le début c'est tout
simplement hélène horrible et je la
classe politique
le souligner de toutes les façons
possibles aujourd'hui oui absolument
plusieurs discours à la chambre des
communes
évidemment on a utilisé les paroles
usage mais quand même moi j'ai constaté
quelques glissements et notamment dans
cette façon que monsieur trudeau a eu
deux d'étiqueter le geste comme un acte
terroriste sans n'est peut-être un mais
pour l'instant me semble-t-il qu'on n'a
pas de preuve à cet effet pas que ça
rende le geste plus grave ou moins
graves
il est horrible et il est dans l'absolu
mais le code criminel définit le
terrorisme de manière très précise et
c'est de terroriser les gens ou non une
cause politique religieuse ou
idéologique et on n'a aucune preuve dans
ce cas-ci que cet homme agissait au nom
d'une cause c'était plutôt me
semble-t-il la haine qu'il animait et il
semble y avoir de plus en plus de
confusion au canada entre le terrorisme
et la haine
c'est pas grave comme je le dis mais
quand même les mots devraient avoir un
sens si on devrait respecter
ouais michel david webb un peu importe
la définition qu'en donne du terrorisme
qui est certain que sur la communauté
musulmane que ce soit en ontario où
ailleurs au pays
sa quête de la crainte alors de la terre
et de la terreur à l'ordre dans ce sens
là on peut on peut parler de terrorisme
au sens large
mais ce qui m'a frappé aujourd'hui
évidemment les discours étaient
de circonstance je peux dire bien que
jeanjean
je n'ai absolument pas leur sincérité en
question mais c'est aussi un sentiment
le sentiment d'impuissance à dire que
c'est pour la première fois et et on
sait tous que ça peut se reproduire et
qu' il est très difficile de
et de prévenir ça dans ce cas si ce
compromis le
l'auteur du massacre il faut l'appeler
comme ça avait aucun lien avec quelques
groupes qu'on connaisse et c'était la
même chose lors de deux attaques la
grande mosquée québec on peut essayer de
faire d'éducation on peut essayer de
civiliser les réseaux sociaux mais à un
moment donné il ya des choses qu'on ne
peut pas éviter et ça je pense que tout
le monde en est parfaitement conscient
dans la classe politique et dans la
société en général
martin je pense avec québec sap a fait
jaser autant qu'on aurait pu penser je
pense que la classe politique et
horrifiés par ce qui est arrivé hier on
a vu que monsieur legault avait twitté
il a dénoncé des gestes racistes et
barbare mais aujourd'hui on n'a pas
parlé il ya ouvert sa conférence de
presse sur autre chose c'est et rappelez
vous qu'il ya quelques mois pendant les
cérémonies le quatrième
la commémoration du quatrième
anniversaire de l'attentât de la mosquée
de québec monsieur legault avait été
fortement questionné sur la question du
racisme systémique et on sent qu'il est
mal à l'aise avec ce thème là et
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas mis lui-même le
sujet devant y attendais je pense plus
plus les questions des journalistes qui
ne sont pas venus cela dit c'est sûr que
si c'était survenu au québec monsieur
legault aurait dit quelque chose mais
comme c'est en ontario
il avait notamment sa relève peut-être
des deux solitudes plus qu'autre chose
en tout cas ça monte pas ce que vous
dites ça serait arrivé à au québec et ne
leur est pas ici marie mais même dans
les médias croient qu'on nous on est là
il ya eu cette conférence de presse avec
monsieur trudeau où il giornale sera non
beaucoup parlé et ont essayé de faire un
lien de lui faire faire un lien entre ce
geste haineux et la loi 21 au québec qui
encouragerait une discrimination envers
les musulmans alors vous font entendre
c'est en anglais le premier bout on le
traduit ou monsieur trudeau répond
qu'ensuite ils continuent ils à va dire
ce qu'il va dire qu'on va parler de moi
dit le great white axes portent elles
par rapport à la perspective personnelle
les gens savent très bien que je suis
pas d'accord avec la loi 21 mai nous
allons laisser les québécois eux mêmes a
amené cette loi-là en cours mais ça me
surprendre époque à dans les semaines et
les mois à venir il y ait des réflexions
à avoir sur le but et l'importance de la
loi 21 en partie parce que ça fait un an
qu'on passe beaucoup de temps avec des
masques qui couvrent nos visages en
obtenant des services de l'état et aussi
parce qu'il ya une réelle inquiétude par
rapport à la montée d'intolérance et
d'islamophobie
écoutez je pense que les québécois
savent pas la différence entre un masque
pour se protéger d'un virus d'un masque
qui est parti pour des raisons
religieuses
donc on le sait une majorité de
québécois qui sont d'accord avec la loi
21 qui sont d'accord pour interdire les
signes religieux pour les personnes qui
sont en autorité puis monsieur trudeau
bain devrait prendre un acte de ce que
souhaite la majorité des québécois
donc je résume loi 21 ce que monsieur
trudeau ça attise la haine il répond non
mais après dans une réflexion il dit est
ce que la pandémie puis les masques ne
serait pas de nature à faire réfléchir
les québécois michel david qu'est ce que
vous avez trouvé à dire la question qui
lui est adressée je les trouvais non
seulement déplacé mais même vicieuse
l'attentât a eu lieu à
en ontario c'est pas la loi 21
s'applique pas en ontario et je pense
pas que ça peut savoir une grande
influence sur les esprits la boîte dans
le centre ce qu'on voulait faire dire à
monsieur trudeau pour ce qui est du lien
entre la pandémie le masque la loi 21 la
tolérance c'est tout à fait hors d'or je
pense que les gens comme dit monsieur
logo où les gens font parfaitement la
différence
la même façon qu'à écouter dans les
hôpitaux les médecins les infirmières
par des masques depuis toujours et on
n'a jamais pensé que ça pouvait avoir un
lien ou une quelconque influence sur sur
les gens par rapport au port de masques
ou que les services soient rendues à
visage découvert non non là je pense
qu'on cherche vraiment à faire des
mauvais procès ouais hélène vous étiez
cette conférence de presse de poser des
questions donc il ya eu plusieurs
tentatives de vos deux collègues
anglophones pour faire le lien entre la
haine et le projet pour le projet et la
loi 21 plusieurs tentatives
oui a pas juste eu une pression en fait
ces trois questions de trois
journalistes différents qui ont fait
cette adéquation entre london et eloi 21
moi je trouve quand même intéressant que
monsieur trudeau en fait aux dits oui et
non à la fois il répond d'abord non à la
question mais ensuite dans l'extrait que
vous avez d'ailleurs fait jouer on
l'entend bien à la fin lorsqu'il dit
mais les gens auront des réflexions par
rapport à la mode la loi 21
considérant la montée de l'intolérance
et de l'islamophobie alors si c'est pas
de faire un lien entre les deux mois je
sais pas ce que c'est par ailleurs son
commentaire sur le masque des montres
qui comprend mal toute la dimension de
ce débat là lui quand il dit mais ça
fait un an qu'on a des services de
l'étop en étant tout en étant masqué et
c'est pas un problème il semble dire que
la loi 21 ce n'est qu'une question de
sécurité et d'identification
d'abord la loi 20 heures ce n'est pas
que sur le voile intégral qu'elles
s'appliquent se sont tous les symboles
religieux et ensuite ce qui a animé le
gouvernement s'est pas seulement de
pouvoir identifier les citoyens de
pouvoir s'assurer qu'on recompte wenger
une personne mais c'est aussi dans le
symbole signal qu'on envoie quant à la
laïcité des potes hétéros
alors monsieur trudeau est assez
réducteur marseille joue dans la parole
mais je vous faire jouer entre un tweed
d'une collecte du globe
chroniqueuse je vais traduire rédige bon
c'est juste a dit je me répète mais si
les leaders fédéraux veulent s'attaque à
l'islamophobie au canada il pourrait
commencer par avoir le courage de
dénoncer la loi québécoise qui interdit
aux personnes portant le hijab et
d'autres symboles d'occuper certains
emplois donc ça revient là haut au
canada anglais martin et mais au québec
aussi à des gens contre la loi il faut
le dire on continue à faire le lien dans
la loi 21 dans le fond skalli cible
c'est les musulmans pas sélectionner que
les musulmans qui porte le voile
ouais mais l'ailier quand même bois tu
l'as entre
ce qui est arrivé à london et un couvre
visage filmé en fait il qu'on parle ni
câble quand le visage est couvert
religieusement ce ni câble et il le
masque sanitaire
ici à québec on n'a pas trop on était
très surpris de la déclaration de
monsieur legault et monsieur legault a
fait un choix réfléchi c'est à dire
qu'il a il a donné une réponse très
tempéré parce que c'est fini les
chicanes inutile on veut pu avoir ce
genre de débat là mais on ne trouvait
que c'était boîte us que monsieur
trudeau et on se demande un peu ci s'est
pas trompé en fait y avait beaucoup de
points d'interrogation il s'était bec
sur cette déclaration est michel sa mort
que puis l'ajout système chronicles y en
a d'autres ça manque que ce débat-là
dans le résume le gros du débat
d'occupation québec dont ça comme ça
mais quoiqu'il pro fini ça va continuer
en cours etc
mais il y en a beaucoup pour qui il ne
prend pas il n'accepte pas monsieur
trudeau ne se soit pas levés contre
cette loi là au québec
absolument et bon dès le départ partout
au canada anglais dans les maisons parce
qu'il est aussi on s'est élevé contre la
loi 21 est bon il ya peut-être eu un
certain essoufflement et la de la dram
de london le donne un nouveau souffle
à ces attaques la et j'ajouterais
peut-être que la loi 96 puis
l'affirmation de la nation québécoise
ça aussi ça contribue à commander à
raviver l'allergie qui qui est toujours
là contre toute affirmation de la
différence québécoise par un moment
donné on a tous dans le même bateau et
la réaction de la chroniqueuse me
surprend tellement apport fait écouter
puis s'arrêterait pas là c'est parce que
ça vous surprend importe qu'elle ait
choisi de faire graver est un exemple
pour montrer que c'est une mauvaise
qu'elle a choisi aujourd'hui mardi quand
même à moins de 24 heures d'un drame
épouvantable
mais en fait ça va plus loin encore que
la loi 21
j'écoutais elizabeth may à la chambre
des communes dans son discours justement
sur l'événement de london qui disait
nous avons tous une part de
responsabilité et désormais il faudra
dénoncer tout politicien qui essaiera de
nous diviser sur la question du hijab
donc on entendait dans son discours
qu'il ne fallait plus questionné le port
du hijab parce que c'était quelque chose
qui menait à la haine et donc aux
massacres comme à london alors ça peut
toucher
oui la loi 21 et le port de symboles
religieux par l'état mais aussi le vote
à visage découvert dont les
conservateurs ont parlé les prestations
du du serment de citoyenneté pour les
nouveaux immigrants madame et semblait
nous dire que toutes ces questions le ne
sont plus légitimes parce qu'elles
reviennent à mettre à remettre en
question les certaines pratiques
musulmanes et donc d'endosser la haine
envers eux
c'est d'aller très loin et je sens que
c'est une tendance quand même assez
lourdes du côté du canada anglais aucune
conclusion sur un autre sujet avant de
se quitter
ne passez pas vaccinale il semble depuis
qu'on a écouté monsieur trudeau monsieur
legault aujourd'hui quand on fait la
somme qu on lit entre les lignes on
comprend qu'en juillet les doubles
vacciner pourront revenir beaucoup plus
en paix au pays une fois qu'ils auront
voyagé ou pourront même aller aux états
unis donc le fameux passeport vaccinale
il va existe
martin ici on parle d'une preuve
vaccinale ils sont très peu allergiques
au mot passe par vaccinale mais je pense
que c'est plus grosso modo à peu près la
même chose mais effectivement on est en
train d'arriver ce que dit monsieur dubé
aujourd'hui c'est que c'est vraiment
pour les voyageurs et on s'est bien
gardé de cibler des restaurants ouvrent
des salles de spectacle mais on sent
qu'il va y avoir autre chose l'avenir
sûrs c'est ce que les deux bleus
vacciner vont avoir certains privilèges
regarder les bases définies salle on
autorise les balles pour ceux qui auront
une dose et on autorise d'autres choses
pour ceux qui ont deux doses à l'enfant
va vraiment vers des ddc pas si michel
poursuite des voyages je pense qu'ils
étaient entendus pas mal que ce serait
exigée puis pas juste au canada de tous
les transporteurs au monde je pense vont
avoir fait les gouvernements vont avoir
à peu près les mêmes exigences quant au
voyage
pour le reste je serais très surpris moi
que le gouvernement impose la preuve
vaccinale comme bon c'est déjà exclu
pour les services essentiels santé
éducation
mais même pour les restaurants le
théâtre par exemple je pense qu'ils vont
plutôt dire il ne sera pas interdite aux
restaurateurs d'exiger une preuve
vaccinale mais c'est pas de gouvernement
qui voilent l'exigé très bien il anime
même si je suis pas certain je suis pas
certaine
voyage oui mais moi je sens beaucoup de
réticences et contenus tous ouvrent déjà
sans même qu'on ait nos deux doses dans
quelques semaines est ce que ça sera
utile
merci beaucoup à vous trois merci
bonjour au revoir pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez vous sur la
chaîne ici et redit